[Applaudissements]
bonjour je m'appelle
20 j'ai 37 ans j'ai un enfant et
contrairement à ce qu'on peut attendre
d'un speaker tedx je suis un de
12 heures c'est vrai je suis un vrai
looser
j'ai commencé ma carrière
professionnelle en loose en ma première
boîte
j'en ai même écrit un bouquin qui
s'appelle les cinq conseils pour couler
sa boîte qui s'est pas vendu je vous ai
dit la loose du début à la fin je vais
vous épargner les premières années de
mon enfance que j'ai fait aussi plein de
conneries on va démarrer directement
après ma prépa deux ans de prépa en
banlieue parisienne et j'ai eu la chance
truc de ouf de rentrer à lui m j'étais
ultra fier alors pour ceux qui
connaissent pas le m
on a pas mal parlé dans les médias
dernièrement mais moi j'étais super
super content de rentrer dans cette
école flatté et ultra motivés tellement
motivé que j'ai monté un groupe de
copains pour candidater pour la gestion
du bureau des élèves
en gros c'est l'association la plus
prestigieuse à l'école on appelle ça me
secundo par une liste et les élections
une campagne on a des épreuves à suivre
pour avoir cette association et croyez
le ou pas mais j'ai quand même réussi
l'exploit de me faire virer de ma propre
liste
avant le début la campagne pas mal de
mecs
alors pour tout vous dire j'ai pas qui
fait le truc a priori je n'étais pas
assez consensuelle et je faisait pas
l'unanimité
ok j'étais pas tout le temps sympa j'ai
même appelé à voter pour la liste
concurrente
et de là les quelques années qui me
restent très bas il restait un peu loin
quoi parce que du coup fallait pas trop
s'approcher
cette aventure m'a fait comprendre un
truc si je voulais être chef
moi j'avais créé ma propre boîte au
moins là je pourrai pas me faire virer
du coup en fin de première année à
l'école plutôt que de partir en stage à
l'étranger
j'ai créé ma boîte une boîte de bijoux
pour cheveux
de fabrication distribution de bijoux
pour cheveux qui s'appelait lucifer
tintin créativité 2000 pour cent et ce
n'est pas le pire
je connais rien à la voiture je vois pas
les couleurs et je porte pas de bijoux
pour cheveux
enfin si une fois une fois il ya un
journaliste qui est venu au bureau du
magazine capital qui lui fait un
reportage sur les bijoux il me demande
si loin tu peux montrer ses bijoux et à
quoi ça ressemble commence à semer dans
les cheveux montrez vous n'avez pas de
perruque à proximité du coup j'ai mis
des bijoux dans mes cheveux
quelques semaines après edward bond
meilleur pote qui m'appelle l'été chez
gentil je crois au cl tu as fais ça tu
es en pleine page donc capital avec des
bijoux dans les cheveux au la
honte or coup de bol c'était en 2005
internet n'existait pas ou presque pas
donc ya pas de trace enfin je crois pas
sauf si on cherche bien en tout cas ça
s'est pas passé comme je voulais et je
vais vous éviter toutes les histoires de
liquidation judiciaire de procès de
dettes et de milliers d'erreurs j'ai pu
faire dans cette boîte parce que malgré
tout c'était superbe aventure ya une
leçon j'ai retenu de ça c'est qu'il faut
pas aller à contre-courant
c'est peut-être à contre-courant de dire
qu'il faut pas aller à contre-courant
dans une conférence sur le
contre-courant certes mais je
m'expliquais à l'école on a tendance à
nous dire que quand on lance sa boîte il
faut être un peu à contre-courant pour
trouver une innovation de rupture pour
connaître le succès c'est pas si simple
- qu'est-ce que je peux vous dire que
mon histoire c'est qu'elle est à
contre-courant de soi même sa garantie
clairement pas le succès vraiment pas
pas si vous l'avez au tribunal précise
mais ne marche pas à chaque fois ce qui
était cool c'est que j'ai quand même
trouvé du boulot je vais chercher du
travail
ce qui était moins cool c'est que j'ai
été chercher au 26e étage à la défense
de la tour romain chan dans le conseil
dans l'audit et que ça me faisait pas
vraiment rêver emma beal aux
entrepreneurs y avait quand même
énormément évolué depuis le démarrage et
j'ai choisi de me lancer dans un projet
cette fois ci le projet est né en deux
pages de business plan et trois grands
principes 1
cette fois ci je voulais me payer dès le
premier jour et au moins 1500 euros nets
ce qui n'avait même pas été le cas
pendant les six ans laventure lucifer 2
je voulais faire un job où je pouvais
apprendre tous les jours où je pouvais
m'éclater professionnellement et 3
je voulais te fier de ce que je
produisais je voulais qu'on tende et léo
que vous tous les matins et je voulais
garder un peu de temps pour faire des
choses à côté
mon pote vincent qui était investisseurs
chez lucifer avait résumé ça dans les 3f
fun fric et fois il m'avait dit pour
qu'une boîte survive il faut au moins
deux des f
il faut s'éclater et une argent et où
croire en son projet moi mon but c'est
d'avoir les trois et c'est de là que
j'ai créée en 2009
sido une agence d'ingénierie pédagogique
et maintenant tu aides pour nous ça a
été un truc super important parce que
y'a une vidéo qui m'a réellement inspiré
qu'inspirant tout le monde s'habille de
la plus vue donc je suis pas du tout
original c'est celle de ken robinson sur
l'éducation
ils ont fait une version où la vidéo est
destinée comme ça à la main j'ai trouvé
ça extraordinaire avec 6 2 on a été les
premiers en france en 2011 en 2011 à
importer cette technique de vidéos
pédagogiques dessinée en tête que vous
avez déjà vu de nos productions
parce que ces ciseaux qui produit les
vidéos dessine-moi l'écho qui sont
diffusées sur lemonde.fr tous les mois
gratuitement depuis le 24 février 2012
un moment assez magique pour nous de
voir notre vidéo dont une du monde.fr
néanmoins pour l'anecdote j'avais envoyé
deux projets à l'éducation nationale en
disant on va qu'on va créer des vidéos
avec des experts en économie
chaque mois gratuitement et cela
pourrait être un contenu intéressant
pour vos enseignants pour aider à la
formation de l'économie au lycée ou à
l'université
je fais un beau dossier j'ai reçu une
belle lettre qui se résume en quatre
phrases qui en gros c'est bien votre
truc
mais la vidéo c'est pas un moyen de
noble de transmettre des informations
complexes cordes et dont on est quand
même allé à contre-courant aujourd'hui
dessine-moi l'écossé plus de 50 millions
de vues du monde francophone
c est référencée dans
tous les manuels d'économie tous les
manèges colère et sido compte 18
collaborateurs a fêté cette année ses 10
ans il ya plein de projets de croissance
sauf que après 4-5 ans je me suis un peu
ennuyé je suis parti sur un nouveau
projet thil qui une solution dead à
l'efficacité commerciale
basiquement on met des traqueurs
invisibles dans les documents qui sont
envoyées du coup quand un commercial
envoie son offre un prospère on lui dit
si ça a été lu quelle page
combien temps par page dans quel ordre
ça a été transmis à cannes grasse qui
les intéressaient extérieur et tout ça
c'est légal en gros ça un big brother du
document
c'est magique juste un peu flippant
voire complètement terrifiant je vous la
corde après moi c'était dans mon propre
courant et jeté à l'aise avec ça ça fait
cinq ans qu'on vit une superbe aventure
on est à lyon et à londres
on grandit bien et on s'éclate et voici
ma dernière co-création léonie bientôt
deux ans alors ça pète en surprendre
quelques uns voir heurté certaines
sensibilités
j'ai aussi écrit un business plan ou en
sorte de business plans avant de
concevoir leoni je vous vois là bas
imaginez la scène
c'est pas cool c'est dégueu je suis
balèze on se calme je vais vous
expliquer en fait le truc c'est que moi
dans mes représentations familiale déjà
je voulais un truc je voulais pas fois
risqué ma famille j'allais fort et plein
de trucs jusque là mais ça je n'ai pas
le droit pourtant entre mes parents mes
copains qui séparait alors qu'il venait
juste d'avoir un enfant ceux qui
passaient leur temps à s'engueuler ce
qu'on voyait plus parce qu'ils aient
plus temps de rien franchement avoir un
gosse ça faisait pas arrivé voir moi ça
me terrifiait j'en fait pour moi que
c'est ça et je n'en voulais pas enfin
non pourquoi
sauf que ma chérie albacete oui c'était
bas maintenant ce serait cool mais
pourquoi ces horribles enfants
on a commencé à poser sur le papier
notre vision ma famille on a été jusqu'à
rédiger un pacte
on s'est engagé sur nos droits nous de
voir nos engagements en ce qui concerne
à peu près tout l'argent comment le
dépense qu'est ce qu'on va acheter pour
notre fille ou pas les vacances c'est ce
qu'on en prend avec elle sans elle est
ce qu'on l'a confié à des gens est ce
qu'on va la faire garder est-ce qu'on va
prendre une poussette quel type de
poussette est ce qu'on fait toujours du
sport des soirées ha ha ha jusqu à la
baisse quel est le nombre de bèze
minimum par mois pour qu'on reste un
couple uni oui oui je vous garantis
qu'on a mis ça dans notre pacte
on a appelé ça le minimum de bèze
hygiénique ah oui j'entends certains
sourire parce que on ne sait pas ce que
c'est d'avoir un enfant avant d'avoir un
enfant où on ne sait pas ce que c'est
les parents avant d'être parents
pourtant moi toutes ces peurs on a
réussi à trouver une réponse à deux nous
a permis de nous lancer dans l'appareil
parentalité de façon assez sereine voire
très sereine franchement ça fait deux
ans sénart aventure incroyable
sauf que comme je suis quelqu'un d'assez
égoïste pour moi une famille c'est quand
même trois entités funk à accueillir
l'enfant s'est gardé trois entités soit
puisque faut pas s'oublier
on a des passions des envies un job in
vie c'est son couple c'est pas parce
qu'on a un enfant que coûte de plus
voire seul depuis faire soirée doit pu
aller au resto de plus parler et enfin
la famille est clairement l'enfant va
créer un déséquilibre de dengue là
dedans et nous on essaie d'en parler
alors clairement le gamin a pris vachon
en plus d'importance que ce qu'on avait
imaginé
mais ça se passe plutôt bien et un jour
je vais voir mon petit fils je raconte
ici tu t'en rapidement les dissidents
qui est complètement barré
pourquoi t'as fait ça impacte avant-hier
un mot flamber sauf qu'après dix buts
d'explication les dix ans fait son
projet c'est dingue et je suis prête à
payer pour qu'ils écrivent un bouquin là
dessus dans ce bouquin on a mis les 300
question qu'on s'est posée qui autour de
nous ont généré des disputes pour que
nous on se mettre d'accord avant un
dispute fait c'est toujours plus facile
de répondre au sujet tant condor est
temps qu'on baise parce qu'une fois
qu'on a un enfant tout en l'oubli et du
coup le moins de problème devient tout
de suite une grosse dispute là pas très
compliqué
alors oui ce bouquin tu as peu à
contre-courant de contractualiser
l'arrivée d'un enfant
ouais ça matières parfois d'antipathie
des gens qui me détestent avoir fait sa
voir même des haters
mais je m'en fous de bouquets en marche
il est dans mon courant à moi ça pour
dire que je cherche pas être le vilain
petit canard
c'est pas fait exprès parce que c'est
pas drôle on se prend des de
claque qui est des jours bah faut se
relever et c'est pas évident tout cas
moi si aujourd'hui je suis à
contre-courant c'est peut-être par mes
choix mais c'est clairement pas par
choix
je remercie
[Applaudissements]